I've always known that you are
very thoughtful and analytical about
what you're doing and it got me thinking
about you as a kid and thinking okay and
I can identify with this
I was funny in a very private way quiet
way
but not out loud to a lot of people I
always say I was not the class clown
neither was that yeah and what were you
like I was
well first off I didn't go to the same
school for more than two years until
high school so I just got bounced all
over the city of Birmingham
so humor was the tool
to
kind of be like if someone cracked on me
or made a joke about me
I'd laugh at all sometimes I'd
self-deprecate yeah tag myself sure
maybe jab you back but just keep it
peaceful but I did not want a lot of
attention on me because attention was
bad like that was a
you're inviting the bullies I think I
read somewhere that once you used to
talk to your hamster yeah yeah guinea
pig yeah Joel yeah going to the room
full-blown conversation like hey I
disagree yeah yeah you're actually
getting any response yeah not like just
you only understand me like yes what do
you think oh really
today they would medicate you that's the
problem not realizing that that was the
medication because that was the outlet
I went outside I played I stayed out of
trouble for the most part in the
neighborhood
uh my mom got me a really nice
basketball goal there was a park
up the street I grew up on the West Side
um and there was a park on Pearson
Avenue called powderly Park and that was
the free public park with the courts
putting me drinking and fighting in it
like there was always something going on
so my mom to keep me from going to
powderly all the time she got me in the
boys club and then she also put a
basketball goal in my yard and the way
our yard was set up
we had really high trees so we had the
only shaded driveway
in Peak 1pm
Alabama heat so everybody would come
from powderly why plan direct sunlight
when you go play a Roy Woods house
and so people just come to and it was
very smart of your mom to to do that
because it's they say when you become a
parent and then your kids as mine are
teenagers everyone says you want your
house to be the base
you want people coming over to your
house because it's safer yeah yeah and
all you have to do is my mom is just
listen for the dribble of the ball so
you know I'm out there yeah and so that
became a way that I met everybody in the
neighborhood not a respect to my father
my parents all the Riff Raff that
happened in powderly never happened at
our house
just on some you know just on some
respect your elders types yeah I want to
make sure I educate anyone who's
listening that you mentioned your father
your father Roy wood senior
was a radio broadcasting journalism
Pioneer and also in the tranches of the
civil rights movement in the 60s yeah
and you've said he was there's any march
with Dr King in it your dad good chance
three worlds back he's probably three
rows back
um
and people in the neighborhood then knew
that obviously
and that respect probably emanated out
from your father and your mother a
thousand percent gave you some some
sense of protection my father was the
voice in the car when their parents took
them to school doing the news on the
black radio station so you can listen to
all the black music you want in the
morning but when they stop for that news
break on the fives
that's my pops yeah so
that that got me a lot of equity
within the city but I wouldn't say that
I was even remotely like on some funny
sense of humor until High School
and even then it was only baseball
because that was where you could be
silly because it's Sports it's a
permission especially in high school
it's a sports is permission to behave in
ways you're not allowed to at school
hmm so you tell all the crash jokes you
make fun of each other like
and then we would just as a benchwarmer
in high school your job is to Heckle the
other team yeah just Heckle them into
Oblivion and
I was good
because that's all I had to do so there
were days where
I would literally sit
and write
heckles in class to get ready for your
game get ready for the game
like and just that's great brutal
bro like stuff you couldn't even places
you couldn't even go with humor now but
just brutal and just yelling it across
the diamond at a total stranger and
seeing the look of frustration in their
face
like I know I'm getting to you
and then to the point where if you got
the if you got the parents to chuckle
like that was an Applause break
if you got the Umpire to call time out
because the Umpire had to laugh that's a
standing ovation
and that was the goal the goal every
game was to break the empire
but not realizing that that was
essentially
just honing improv China sure yeah and
just working on
crowd work it's a crowd works well all
this stuff it's uh
it's everyone has their own versions
about it versions of it but I know what
you're talking about which is
um you know we I come from a big family
so we all sit around this round table
that's still at my parents house and I
know exactly where I sat and I know that
that's where I tried to get the whole
table laughing I was in JROTC in high
school
and when we would have to do drill
um some mornings and we would start with
running they had like this quadruple
tennis court yeah so we'd have to do
laps around the whole perimeter of this
tennis court
and as we're jogging I'm calling the jog
like a Kentucky Derby
and they're getting to turn two turn two
and they're pulling even it's Roy next
to Monica Monica coming up on the
outside coming up on the inside of
Sergeant Major sergeant major sergeant
major is coming in and you're supposed
to be controlling your breath because
you're running and you're doing this
it doesn't matter
um look falling shorts well it's falling
short but as they get into that
that was that was who I was yeah just so
we're laughing as we're running around
the space and that's when you start
learning about comedy
as this like tool of manipulation
like it's it's literally
I bet you I can make you detour from
whatever your mental objectives are
right now by doing something
it's like tickling with your mouth yes
yes yes
you know uh I'm curious your father this
very revered figure I think he passed
away when you were pretty young yeah 16
16 years old would he have
what would he think of your career in as
a stand-up would he approve of that of
of that move
I don't think so
he would approve now based on the
material that I'm doing now right we
just have to remember
my father like saw every horrible thing
that you could name because he just had
to cover it in the name of Journalism
yeah like foreign war reporting so he
saw like African Civil Wars which are
way worse in terms of
body counts and the heinousness because
a lot of that goes under reported right
so he's seen stuff so nothing's funny to
him and so case in point when he worked
at wvon in Chicago my father was the
first news director at this black owned
black news station we are a news station
that only does black news like it's like
at the end in NPR
stood
say it no so
they were dedicated to the black
experience and uplifting black people my
father hires a guy named Don Cornelius
oh yeah
um to be a DJ he Don Cornelius was a was
a police officer in Chicago he put my
father over gave him a ticket I didn't
know that yeah that's where Don okay Don
cornelius's origin story he was a member
of law enforcement for about a year
maybe less than two for sure
pulls my dad over
in the course of giving my father a
ticket my dad just goes you have a nice
voice here's my card
quit doing this and come by the
radio station so Don Cornelius starts in
radio under my father as a reporter at
wvon and during that time as Don's
understanding the media grows he comes
up with the idea for soul train comes to
my dad my dad was one of the initial
investors
and
gave Don some of the money that he used
ultimately for the first pilot for Soul
Train and then when it came time to get
my dad his money back
John Cornelius goes to my father it's
like hey man
instead of me paying you back
why don't you just stay on board you
know I I wouldn't you know this this is
I just want you to be a part of this
to which my dad told Don Cornelius and I
quote
nobody wants to watch
dance for an hour give me my
money
oh my God so my dad just was not with
party culture yeah he was not doing the
fun he just couldn't see also I mean
yeah and you it's hard to blame him
because of everything he saw and being
in the trenches of the Civil Rights
Movement like that and then what if we
dance all day
froze yes he couldn't see it he couldn't
see it that that celebration of
Blackness creates the black pride that
helps to drive people if you want more
for themselves for their community
couldn't see it
uh when I was in Middle School I was in
a dunk tank
for our soccer team to raise money for
jerseys and my dad came into the dunk
tank and cussed me out and told me to
get out the duct tape
in front of everybody like get out of
there you nobody's fool you ain't gonna
be Nobody's Fool all this joking and
shocking get that lesson I'm like it's a
dunk tank we're raising money it's just
I'm just gonna get splashed in some
water yeah we're raising money so we
have decent uniforms because when you're
a black Middle School you're only
playing whites this is soccer in 88
there's not a lot of black schools
playing soccer so we're playing all of
the our uniforms bro
um ping we had ping we borrowed jerseys
from the partners in neighborhood growth
which was like the Police Athletic
League at the time in Birmingham
so you have a community League that has
jerseys we're barring their jerseys
that's how poor our school was and then
my dad is like nah get your ass up out
of there it was very embarrassing
and I just remember after that I just
never tried to be funny around him again
yeah because just you're not with jokes
bro he was a lot of things he was not
hilarious